I had an incident happen with my wife but she didn't I'm concerned it's been
damaged in some way. A toddler had been in the room where I was staying in a
cabin and unplugged the red bulb cord. So the red cord for the bulb. I started
it up that night and it was really loud yes because your the electricity is
coming out of that that outlet piece of the red cord and it will arc to the
other one. I realized the red cord had been unplugged absolutely pedic
actually switched it to bath for a split second got a little electric shock
then from touching the red empty red plug-in. Yes I've actually turned down my
right when I was actually programming somebody's right. Once it never had a
bulb plugged in and I got shocked. It's not going to get electrocuted. It's not
that high of voltage coming out of that but you will get shocked and it will
scare you. I then just unplugged the power strip of the wall turned it on
and it seemed to work fine but I'm second-guessing it. So at most in doing
something like this you will you know worst-case scenario bird out to
transistor on the back but really you'll blow a fuse before you do that. So you
didn't hurt your wife so don't worry. I don't remember the red on but the blink
key when there was no program running and I feel like the bulb seems
dimmer. I ran the 22nd bulb check it lit up like it said it should. Now how do I
know if there's internal damage there if it's working you don't have internal
damage you didn't hurt the right. Don't worry about it. It hurt the right it wouldn't
work and and then the first thing you would do is go back to the rife section on
the member site or go to the rife course and go to the troubleshooting guide and
the first thing it'll tell you to do is to you know check your oh let's check
everything like that and then check the fuse. So worst really case scenario it's
something like this you would have blown the fuse that's what a fuse is for. So but
you didn't blow the fuse and it works just fine.